so our next speaker is matuster garsky
from University of Illinois at
Urbana-Champaign and he will talk about
future selection with gradient descent
on two layer networks with low rotation
regimes
okay thanks a lot gal for introducing me
and uh thanks everybody for coming
especially people that braved you know a
pandemic and and these sorts of things
and some of you might be a little
concerned if you know that I'm going to
talk about margins that maybe it's weird
that I'm before naughty I'll give a
tutorial but actually it's excellent
because I'm not going to um I'm going to
use margins as a technical tool I'm not
really going to try to philosophically
uh you know say they're not really going
to be the goal I'm going to establish
low sample complexity using margins as a
tool I will not know how to prove these
things without margins so I think it'll
motivate you all to learn more about
margins and go to naughty's talks
tomorrow and I'd like to thank a few
people first so of course I'm very uh
very grateful for being invited again
you can see how happy I am to be in
Berkeley this still smells like plastic
because I literally bought it yesterday
in the uh in the plastic bag I'd also
like to think Zoo a g now at uh Google
research who taught me a lot of what I
know about about margins and I'll say a
couple of his kind of unique ideas today
some there'll be kind of a couple proof
ideas they're his
and I'm very regretful to say that
Googling this title gives you back this
talk it is not an archive despite my
promises for about two weeks now so it's
fair game if somebody wants to put up an
archive instead of me I claim I can have
it up tomorrow but but uh we'll see
um because I will tell you
so I plan to submit it tomorrow morning
which means you can beat me to it
right fair game I'm going to show you
the proof techniques so uh
okay so here's what we're talking about
today I'm studying two layer networks
with the relu and it's very important
that it's two layers and that two layers
are trained and I'm Going to Show Low
sample complexity and my proof technique
will always be margin maximization and
I'm going to have two classes of results
the first are going to sound uh modest
at first until I tell you a little bit
of an evil trick so they're going to
sound modest because I'm going to say
that in a way that I'll formally Define
shortly the margin I achieve is at least
as good as the margin is cheaper than
the ntk
but here are a couple tricks one I exit
the ntk
okay so one of the ways to formally
Define the ntk is that you stay within
for being a storm one of your
initialization
one of my steps of my proof is that the
norm of the first gradient is square
root M the square root of the width I
exit the mtk in that formal definition
ndk in the first step
so that's one of the twists
the other twist is that
proofs that used margins in the ntk they
could not actually establish that you
achieve a large margin the reason is
that the way you measure the margin
within the ntk regime is you subtract
off initialization the way that margins
are typically used is without the
initialization subtracted off you do the
conversion you get a one over root M
Factor on your margin so with this proof
I'll give the first result
that gives a constant lower bound on the
margin that you can achieve with uh to
their homogeneous training or any any
homogeneous training as far as I'm aware
um prior work gave non-decreasing
margins but they could be arbitrarily
small like I said I want a rooted M
Factor and this also implies that um
gradient flow can select uh non-trivial
kkt points so there was this question of
whether gradient flow just goes to the
worst kkt point of the margin objective
and and in this result
um yeah I can say that we select better
ones okay
that's the first class of results and
again
um they're a little bit modest at first
because the margin that I'm referring to
is the ntk margin but then it has these
interesting attributes and in both parts
of the talk
for me the most interesting thing are
the proof techniques so I think I have
not exploited the proof techniques so
I'll spend a lot of time giving them
because I think in both phases a lot of
you can do better than what I did using
my lemmas so the second class of results
um
they're better and they're worse so for
these I'm able to prove essentially
Global Max margin results but they have
a almost endless number of caveats so
the first is I'm using gradient flow
and for some of them I can do gradient
descent but our priori these are
non-algorithmic results right it takes
countably infinitely many steps to produ
to run this algorithm and the other is
my my width is exponential in dimension
okay so in that sense it's it's a
negative result but what I can prove
here one is there was a uh
no I mean I proved the result but I'm
saying it's negative that my width has
to be exponential so my proofs in the
second half so the first half the it's
polynomial in one over gamma but in the
second half the uh currently it uses
Xmas with but that is not intrinsically
in the proof technique so I have two
results here one is there's a certain
interesting type of data presented by um
Donahoe David donoho and some of his
colleagues they called it neural
collapse and basically of data
reporting sort of more than orthogonally
and um so I'm able to show that if you
consider the predictor which just puts
all of the values pointing in these
directions uh the margin I achieved is
is at least as good as this one so I can
I can beat this which means that I'm
doing at least as good as moving all the
rotating all the rallies to go in those
directions
the second result
um so what happens here the difference
in this second in the second setup and
the original setup is I've introduced
the parameter b a scalar B so what's
going on here is that my inner layer is
not allowed to rotate the notes can't
rotate I'm only changing their Norm
okay so I've removed the rotation and in
this case I can prove Global Max margin
and again a lot of you might be saying
um you know who cares about margins
sounds like a weird idea there were
there were there were questions in the
last two talks to go when Spencer was
talking you know when is this condition
this margin condition satisfied is it
even a good thing to work with I'm going
to spend the next two slides justifying
at least for first of this talk why it's
a very good idea to use margins in the
analysis gradient descent
okay so this is the setup of the talk
any questions
and I just want to say that here's a
summary of the technical contributions
so in the first phase I have this root M
for BDS Norm which to me is quite
perplexing I mean by the way I do SGD so
the squared gradient Norm term with
constant exercise the greatest Norm term
is order m
or M can be arbitrary large and STD
still works
okay so I didn't have an exploited this
I basically 99.99 of the time that was
required for me to produce this work was
finding a certain potential function
for 99999 of the time and I will show
you that potential function in full
detail on how I derived it and also just
a last note
in place the fabinia storm I often use
this which is something between the
verbena storm and the operator Norm
there are many results I prove using
this Norm which I do not know how to
prove if I use it use the Rubino storm
in place of it very technical comment
but uh it started driving me crazy every
place in the proof I had a previous term
I'd try both
okay so let me show you some pictures so
uh this is not a talk focused on sparse
parity but especially in light of you
know recent uh recent interests by many
authors uh I realize it's something that
can kind of excite a lot of us
so I just want to say what these results
do if we consider the problem of two two
bit uh two sparse parity so let me just
explain the problem to you
so in all these experiments I'm running
up here I have 64 data points and 20
Dimensions so I'm only showing the
two-dimensional projection and I'm using
width 1664 and 256.
what's up here plotted right now is 16
with 16. so the data is in 20 Dimensions
normalized to uh uh have uh
including Norm one
and the label is just a product of the
first two coordinates okay so this is
the sparse parity
and just just throw it out there the
global Max Martin solution in this case
is just
you know you like you if you can tie
your shoes you know with the global
maximum solution is you just pick four
values pointing like this and it's very
easy to prove everything you want about
about that solution it's just very nice
to work with Okay so I just wanna I was
very inspired and I think many people
have by running these experiments in
detail so let me just show you what I'm
plotting here what I'm plotting are the
trajectories
of all the values all 16 of them they're
blue if the outer weight is positive
they're red if the outer weight is
negative okay so that if we're getting
good classification or we'd expect all
the Reds to go along with the red points
and again it's 20 dimensional data I've
projected it down to two so the the data
points just appear in these two
dimensional clusters
okay so it's I mean we could waste the
whole talk just staring at these because
the first thing you notice is that
gradient descent
uh has quite a bit of trouble
you know like what this one's why why
didn't this one go this way
why you know why didn't it go this way
and and why is this blue one coming back
this way you know we could do this we
could do this all day okay but but
there's a lot of interesting patterns
here I'll just highlight two of them
that are relevant to the proofs one is
that the nodes do not move the same
speed okay the ones that start out
putting in a good direction most of them
go a lot faster if this plot extended it
goes way farther so most of the bulk of
the forbidia storm is down to a couple
nodes
the other thing I'm plotting here is I'm
plotting
so I run it I run a lot of iterations
and I'm plotting
um
I take every weight
so every inner weight and an inner
product with itself at time zero and
time T okay so I see how much that
weight rotates and it's normalized so I
do like the koshy Schwartz thing this
should be at most one
and the interesting pattern I observed
which maybe it's reported in literature
I don't know but um as I increase the
width this curve goes strictly up so all
of the nodes rotate less
so at least with larger width it's not
really feature learning it's more like
feature selection the ones that were
good at first stay good the ones that
are bad kind of get ignored and so
that's why feature selection so go ahead
yeah so this one here so I have in this
in this figure I have um 16 weights okay
so I have 16 wigs my inner layer what I
do is I look at the inner layer every
node in the inner layer at Time Zero
so I didn't normalize it it is at time
zero and an inner product it with
uh what it's doing at time t
okay so I'm plotting this for all 16
nodes and I sorted I sorted the output
of this
yeah so the thing is is that I ran all
of these until I achieved a certain
margin uh I don't remember how I picked
this to be honest it was I was getting
um
I think I did it based on the test error
but uh but then eventually I just just
ended up doing like a hundred thousand
uh creating decent iterations so the
y-axis is this quantity once
yeah so the x-axis I have uh 16 of these
and I'm going to superimpose the result
for 64 and 256 that's why the X6 goes up
to 26. so I have 16 16 bars for 16
weights the ones that are blue are the
ones that at time T their outer weight
is positive the ones that are red their
outer weight is is a negative so it
corresponds to the colors over here if
we counted the number of red curves over
here and blue curves that match the
number of so yeah maybe it's clear if I
do two more steps
um so there's the curve so I've run it
with m equals 64 now and actually this
just became really degenerate it gets
really confused and indeed you see the
fact that it's strictly above the old
one and after 164 then we get a few
minutes other one and the margins stay
roughly the same units do you see we
could spend the whole talk here yeah the
bars are just sorted by their height
yeah I mean but I find this endlessly
fasting like by by like uh
let's say cookie cutter concentration of
measure you would expect them in 1526
you would expect it actually not to have
a minimum that's that's it so there's
like very very crazy stuff going on here
if you try smaller than 16 uh 16 is the
smallest I went
um for a lot of mathematical reasons but
uh I'll just leave it too quickly say
like that it can fail it can fail so it
can happen that it just points in the
wrong direction and it gets stuck there
so it has happened to me in fact I
regenerated these for a talk at some
point and I put them in the slides
without realizing I've generated them
with a failure and it was pretty funny
well everybody happy what else did you
use oh yeah so uh I have a certain
religion it's called the logistic laws
do you know whether there are Equity
points other than this uh yeah there are
tons of 2k2 points I mean it depends on
how we want to uh do the quotienting on
the space of kkq points because of
course we can like duplicate nodes in
either direction and stuff like that
um there are kkt points where of course
you just delete certain directions
um but but for for uh there are also
these really terrible kkt points that
point orthogonals the two Dimensions
I've shown there is a tremendous number
of kkt points for this
yeah a lot of them are kind of silly for
this particular data but uh so for this
we aren't experts the extra data is kind
of weird because people have proved a
lot about it but in some sense it's
actually very easy so a lot of the kkq
points are silly
gal's an expert in kdd margin stuff
that's why he's asking okay
I've run a lot of these um yeah there's
many more experiments I can tell you
about I've been running these for a
couple years
okay so and I just want to flash a slide
that's going to give a table of the
sample complexities you can prove for
this and again my main motivation here
is actually to set up not this talk I
want to convince everybody that margins
are a really good way to analyze
gradient descent
okay so uh and I should apologize
um there's a lot of people I'm uh
leaving off this table it's it's just um
there's no positive work we're just
laziness there's a lot of people left
off that I shouldn't have left off I
just want to give a couple results
and I'll split them up sort of into
categories so if you use what I call a
perceptron proof or what um Spencer
called the play aguayashevich group uh
a few years back we got this analysis so
if you run SGD only training the inner
layer but just straight up single back
single example Federation SGD with high
probability you can show if the network
width is for this 2X or network with d
to the eighth you need D Squared of
Epsilon samples and D Squared upon time
to do one that so I just mentioned that
these chord of epsilonis is optimal for
kernel methods so this is the comment I
made during Spencer's talk you don't
lose anything by using margins so the
margin for this problem is 1 over D and
the rate that I'm going to give you is
one of our margin squared times Epsilon
and that's exactly this so you prove the
general theorem you plug in a
calculation using gaussian concentration
for the margin and you get the kernel
optimal but you get the kernel optimal
sample complexity and the proof is not
that complicated
okay I think the proof is actually quite
fun to do and uh
yeah
the proof is is a yeah I mean I
shouldn't say it's not that complicated
because a lot of the key steps were due
to Zoe and they were kind of brilliant
but
um especially my newer one is is
actually quite easy okay so I should say
that there was a degradation in this
proof that um
we got D to the eighth and uh one of the
things I'll show you today is that I get
D Squared D Squared width
okay and that brings the computation
down
uh just another result so this paper
with like 20
uh I guess five six authors or something
it just came out a couple days ago
um so I the authors I remember the
survey goel there's uh Elon malach
there's uh Boaz Barack that I apologize
it was the authors Our member
um so the interesting the thing I want
to highlight is that for all of these
proofs there's a lot of there's a lot of
trade-offs
oh wait who am I missing oh I'm sorry
okay so the thing I want to highlight
here is that there are a lot of
interesting trade-offs so you'll notice
that this paper the highlight of this
paper is that it's width is very small
um but it but it's it's you know it
samples and it's it's computation are
are um are worse than any other column
so the highlight of this paper is this
is this low width and uh I do not know
how to prove this low width with the
perceptron proof technique in fact we
have a lower Bound for the proof
technique so I do not know how to prove
this width there
um okay so yeah I apologize do you want
to see your name out loud yeah
okay good result yeah good job
but yeah again I want to highlight the
trade-offs
um so I also want to say that then
there's a class of results that get do
Global margin maximization over the
space of all relu networks
um and they all get uh this this sample
complexity of repsilon this sort of
style of result was motivated by this
paper by um by Colin way Chengdu Jason
Lee and uh Tong Yuma and um yeah they
kind of I think highlighted this problem
for margin techniques that it can get
the separation with with the ntk and uh
yeah their algorithm was infinite with
and you add noise every single you know
infinitesimal iteration so it's doing
some like non-local search thing uh
chazat and Bach they use just regular
wash and flow on an infinite with
network
but they used one what I would call
Super infinite width so it wasn't just
infinite width they need the nodes to
cover the sphere forever
so they need the weights to be supported
on the sphere for all times T it's not
enough to have exponential width at the
beginning because then you can rotate
away it needs to be covering the sphere
for all times t
and then I had something I'll discuss
later called the Dual convergence
assumption if there's something that uh
you know in terms of like uh things that
frighten me in life proving the Dual
convergence condition that frightens me
so okay and then uh today what I will
show you is that with a modified Network
the one where I do not let the inner
layer rotate
I can get also gradient flow so infinite
time
deal reps on the optimal sample so I get
the global maximum solution and I only
need D to the D with
um but it but it um there's no evidence
that the proof technique actually I know
exactly what to improve in the proof to
do better than that okay so that's the
motivation for also I'd say naughties
talk well from my taste like it's good
to study margins
okay so anyway go ahead so
um
[Music]
yeah so do you mean um yeah so so
nothing's question I realized European
all the questions is if this was the
case for us parody how do all of these
look any unfortunate answer is that I do
not fully know right now because um
uh
this this is one of those things that
prevented me from applying to Archive
like I just have not exactly calculated
them so until I've worked out the margin
the margin Commission in terms of D and
K so I do not know how these will look
interested
but but this one this one is um so this
one is I think K cubed D to the 2K D to
the K that's my recollection yeah
a lot of factors have dropping 12 of
them and that's the only one where right
now I can promise you I know what the
dependence on chaos
um yeah okay so let's uh let's get on
with the proofs and uh
so the first thing I want to tell you
about is the SGD result the theorem
looks like this and let me just uh some
being a little bit theatrical I guess
maybe extended day for all of us let me
just decide what are the most
interesting things to tell you
so I haven't defined for you the the ntk
margin assumption it was in Spencer's
talk but I'll show you briefly but if
the step size is quadratic in
in that margin parameter and the width
is inversely quadratic in that margin
parameter then basically the number of
samples you need for your average to
have good tests there so your average
test error looks like 1 over T gamma
squared okay
let me just make a quick sanity check
comment that if you froze the features
and ran if you froze the features and
ran perceptron like the perceptron proof
by navikov if you just literally copy
paste that you would get one over T
gamma squared so this this is tight with
that the improvement over the prior work
is actually this it's one of our T games
squared not one over t to the gamma to
the eighth
okay
um let me just explain the margin
assumption it was uh it was in Spencer's
talk I'll just explain it in a different
way
so here's a another cute way to sort of
derive the ntk so the networks I'm
working with are two homogeneous
what that means is if I write out the
prediction function on a data point I
which is why I sum j a j
this thing okay this thing is what's
called two homogeneous that means If I
multiply the parameters by a positive
constant C I pull out c squared
so what that what that there's another
there's another way to characterize
homogeneity which is that this is
actually equal to
the gradient
divided by two okay so another way to
look at this is that I have a linear
predictor
in these features now it's a little bit
Shady because both sides of the inner
product depend on W but I can just
decouple them so you can view the margin
assumption as decoupling these so I get
a linear predictor I stick something
over here
this is what I get to vary this year my
linear weights and then I fix these
parameters where W's are drawn from
gaussians that's another way to
interpret the margin condition that
Spencer showed us about two two and a
half hours ago or two hours three hours
ago three and a half hours ago
okay so there's another way to do it and
that's the margin assumption I use
let me just decide what interesting I
should tell you I have to use the
logistic loss the proof breaks
the the Martingale breaks
okay the squared gradient Norm term
breaks if I don't use Logistics the
exponential the proof breaks and it
seems real
uh and yeah once again let me just say
that for parity you can exactly
calculate uh gamma it's 150 times D and
I only know it for two two sparse purity
oh yeah and I should say that I'm using
slightly Pi torch initialization where
the outer layer has variances one over M
and the inner layer has variances one
over d
yeah what's up
what's the quantifier over episode
oh yeah so the weight yeah the way to
interpret it is yeah I'd have a tablet
log the other way so yeah the way to
interpret it is given you get you hand
me a
H yeah Epson has a desired accuracy I I
changed that from trust me so I
apologize the way it should be written
is because this is accuracy the right
hand side there so yeah the way it
should be written is given T if you give
me a t okay then I get this right hand
side you give me a t then with
probability one minus Delta over the
data and over the weights initialization
then I get right hand side which is one
over T gamma squared thank you yeah just
just to repeat uh there's a serious one
wrap someone that doesn't appear
anywhere else in this life
for any teeth but then they're probably
one of the Deltas after that I'm just
saying like the log one of the results
okay
okay
um there's a few more comments about
this
um
yes the prior work uh and it's not just
an issue of moving from one layer train
to two layers trained after zoo and I
did our one layer proof uh and and his
his co-authors they um they adapted our
proof to the multi-layer case but they
also had the eight in the exponent so
something different had to go on inside
the proof for me to get the one over
gamma squared
and uh you know I've only I haven't
really ruled out that I stay in the ntk
here but I'm just saying that the first
gradient step has this huge Norm in fact
the squared rate Norm term like I said
is order M my step size is so that
gradient term really is order M so I
need something special inside the proof
to control that term I can't just kill
it with the step size
okay
um
and so I'll just say that the key of the
proof the rest of it is kind of like
copy paste perceptron the really special
thing uh are this inequality and
variance that I prove there's a version
of this inequality which you will see
tomorrow
um which which actually kind of disturbs
me I proved it in two different ways
it's like algebra that if I massage it
around it doesn't work anymore
um so so that I would say the key new
ingredient is this margin condition if
you find this proof interesting and how
I got the one of our gamma squares is
one over again my eighth
um
uh this is the key ingredient and I
should say if you're also thinking to
yourself why why did you care about this
exponent like who even cares about
margins
um well you'll notice that that the work
that um that they posted just a few days
ago my computation complexity is higher
than theirs with the eighth and it's
better with with the squared so uh it is
useful to compare these techniques
so the the Assumption okay the
assumption is that uh
this infinite width Network so if I do
these expectations over these weights
and then I have this like transport
thing so I assign every AV I give it a
direction this is like my infinite with
weight vector and then I look at the
and this is that initialization so if I
look at the minimum there are multiple
ways of doing it the way I did it for
this theorem was this thing has to be
gamma almost surely so for almost every
X Y because this is a population result
so I need this margin assumption to hold
almost surely over the distribution
anything
any input distribution any participation
that satisfies this condition so you can
view this as a condition on the joint
probability measure over X and Y it's
saying that the joint it's saying that
well if I want to draw it in a silly way
to the Joint probability law has to be
you know has to be supported here but
this is a cartoon right because this is
not nearly separable
but uh yeah it's a the margin assumption
is a strong condition on the joint
probability law on X and Y
which is advantageous because that's how
it's able to you know do better than
than if you did the minimum singular
value of the gram Matrix sometimes
ah and I should say a technical note
this proof even though
this the sample complexity looks like
what you'd get if you applied a margin
generalization bound to your automaker
complexity this proof does not establish
that this is a large margin predictor it
doesn't prove that
that you're actually getting this margin
separation of the data it just gives you
a sample effects that looks as if you
had a large margin okay that distinction
will matter in a few moments
okay yeah go ahead hey no Audrey
previous one it seems like you're
establishing the kind of PL inequality
like uh answer was talking about today
morning but giving that your weights
move so far you're going to speak to how
oh
um yes so there so this is actually
um
this is actually kind of kind of crazy
so uh
uh it's actually best if I do it uh with
with the picture to be honest
uh so I use this so my intuition behind
when I got started with this like six
months ago was that because I used Pi
torch initial initialization where the
inner layer they're all unit Norm so I
figured that all of my air weights can
move
can move gamma individually they can all
move gamma individually and if the data
is separable with margin gamma then it
should still work that was that was my
so a lot of the activations can change
so ntk requires one derivative of the
activation teams that most of them like
gamma fraction can change my group
should go through and that was indeed
true so I was saying that in forbidia
storm might move this much and you can
interpret this as saying that all of the
near layers
does that answer the question a little
bit that's the cute answer the technical
answer is that there's a like there's a
variant of that inequality which
um if you had any cleaner and good on
the board now there's a high chance I
would not be able to prove it
yeah like three out of five times I try
to reprove it I make an incorrect step
and there's just like weird algebra it's
kind of scary but somebody else has
checked it
any good questions any others
I really like to talk about this topic
but I should try to not be so slow
okay so um
for gradient flow I have a qualitatively
different theorem
so this was very interesting to me I I
could not really do the same thing for
gradient flow so there's a qualitatively
different theorem for gradient flow
might just be my math club right like I
just couldn't do it but um especially if
you're curious about margins maybe just
for an exercise you can try to once the
paper is unarchived or somebody else
posts it for me you can try to reprove
this so let me just let me just tell you
what's going on so for this one I can
handle the exponential loss because I
don't need to deal with the the high
variance of the gradients
um the width is the same
and now there's a little bit of a Oddity
going on so the old proof uh it started
somewhere and it moved some distance and
the distance it moved was at most uh
gamma root M now I actually have to move
all the way
I have to move up to gamma root M
exactly
the reason is that the formal definition
of margin is given here it's divided by
the norm squared now the norm squared
when you initialize with random
gaussians has a ton of stuff on the
inside right there's a ton of random
Mass you have to move far to get rid of
that massive that big pile of random
initial weights so this proof actually
moves sort of um
disgustingly far okay impractically far
this is farther than anyone ever stops
in practice
okay so here's where things get weird
if I run
um
I'll tell you how this proved in a
second but if I do a lazy proof
I get gamma squared margin so gamma
squared margin if you convert into
generalization bound it becomes gamma to
the fourth so it's worse than SGD if I
do this ridiculous thing where I
renormalize the inner and outer layer so
I'm just moving a constant between them
so it's Computing the same function
this uh gets me back to the SGD margin
and if I apply a generalization bound to
that now I get back the generalization
Bound for SGD with like a multi-step
weird proof okay again this could just
be my math weakness so this this could
just be an artifact but
I just want to say that for now at least
the SGD and the gradient flow groups are
qualitatively different
yeah this is too homogeneous because I'm
in the tumor genius case
just be clear are you talking about this
Square yeah yeah okay okay because this
is the the
wait w w is a comma V the inner and
outer weights
yeah and for me to homogeneous and
that's why yeah aren't familiar with the
terminology just just once again it's
the two layers multiplied together if I
multiply the whole primary vector by a
positive constant it multiplies the
entire function by c squared after I
pull it through a little bit so to get
the right units in a margin I have to
divide by c squared
uh sorry what's pi in the definition oh
my goodness yeah so so this this
quantity here yeah so Pi is um
so this is so if it's like the Tuple a
comma B this is the like the
unnormalized margin so some j a j Sigma
B J transpose X and W is the
concatenation of A and B yeah
I told this for all of this stuff
okay so let me tell you the what I feel
are the interesting parts of this proof
then I have some other comments oh I
there's okay sorry no audio yeah
there you go
um so
um so here here are a couple shots for
me so the way this proof works is I use
the previous proof scheme to get a
training error bound that looks like the
tester about the previous mode only
gives you training error but if I just
hit that with the generalization bound
it shows it doesn't give me anything It
suffers from that thing I mentioned
earlier that the arbitrarily small then
to my complete uh just confusion if I
use my marginal maximization proof for
coordinate descent from 2013 gives me a
margin of gamma squared okay this was
not by this was not by Construction in
fact I had a separate proof that was
like five pages long and then I realized
I could use my 2013 proof for linear
predictors so I don't I don't understand
how this happened but the proof is like
a three-liner so
what can I say this gives this bound
then um
for this one you use this
re-parameterization
and then uh for for the for the for the
generalization I do something I think is
uh very pretty
so there's a generalization bound due to
um due to Nazi karthikshire darn from
from Cornell and advocatori at Michigan
um from 2010 and they have a they have a
rod marker complexity bound that looks
like one over n okay it's not one over
root n it's one over n why do I care I
wanted the same Bound for um SGD and and
gradient flow that's why I cared about
this now the pretty thing that happens
is let me just explain this
um let's see okay so I'll do it over
I'll do it over here so let me just show
you something kind of fascinating so if
I look at
um
okay let me write it this way so I have
some kind of abstract node which uh
depends on a parameter W J and it's two
homogeneous okay I'm dividing by the
forbidius norm the forbidius norm
squared is the sum of the weight squared
okay if I use two modernity in the
numerator
I get this squared and then the
normalized thing
and then this in the denominator the
point is that these things form a
probability distribution
I'm in the convex Hall of single nodes
so I take uh
so I take notis bound then I take I
guess from Peter's old papers I take the
convex Hall rule for con for radamar
complexity and I get a generalization
that has no dependence even logarithmic
on the width of the network
okay
okay it's pretty uh
I was kind of surprised by all of this
so I'm surprised both of this is so
different from the SGD proof and I'm
also surprised that um the steps are all
kind of weird but anyway that's that's
my story
for for this part any questions about
this
so I did I did not expect to have to dig
so deep and use so many results from
from like I guess 20 years of of stuff I
was just kind of
kind of malaise trying to get a same
Bound for SGD and creative flow
like I said that's an open problem don't
use my my silly complicated proof find a
just just find a clean proof
if there's anything else I said here um
yes this kkt point I can actually
explain this really simply
um
if I just have two data points this is
proved rigorously but let me just
explain it in pictures if I have two
data points
just two posit data points okay then
then the max margin rally solution is
just
just one neuron point in that direction
if I start to move these apart
and they look like two data points
pointing far apart the kkt points at
some point the op the maximum solution
switches over to being two values from
one so now you have two kkt points you
can still pick the one that has both
data points in the receptive field or
you can have two different values
and um at some point it switches over
and this proof is already sufficient to
pick the two value solution it's really
good enough to pick the two value
solution
so it escapes the bad kkt points I
should also say that um I I enjoy the
papers that people produce that say the
word Simplicity bias in the title but I
I find it very difficult to develop
intuition about what is simple and what
is not so when it comes down to what the
global maximum solution is uh and and in
terms of like number of values and stuff
and data with clumps I find that I'm
wrong 99 of the time and I have to do
the algebra to figure out what the Alex
Global Max margin solution is and my
intuition for what simple ends up being
false every time maybe maybe somebody
else is better with the intuition but
but I'm just saying that it's very hard
to argue that the Global Management
solution which it seems gradient flow
selects is um often is is uh simple
right that was just like a minor
philosophical point
okay
as usual I mismatched time but let me
let me just tell you the highlights in
this part
um
so again because my results here are to
my taste quite weak I I will just tell
you the weaknesses and also the the
strength which is the proof technique
and then maybe somebody can use
uh this proof technique
okay so now I'm really comparing with a
legitimate relu network two layer value
Network so as I've mentioned the right
scaling on the outer layer when I write
down a value Network I'm competing with
this to L1 normalize the outer layer and
then I make all the inner layer weights
L2 normalized the inner weights all have
freepiness cleaning Norm one the outer
layer it's it's it's it's L1 Norm is one
for the outer layer
this is the comparator and why is this a
nice comparator well
um the the global maximum solution for
two sparse like I said four values the
margin you get is one over one over root
D so if we can prove the same kind of
bound we did before of one over gamma
squared we get the D over Epsilon so we
have separated ourselves from kernel
methods and this is how all those global
Max margin papers I mentioned work going
back to the
Colin way chenglu Jason Lee and tongima
paper
okay and again this is why I think
margins are cool it's a refined enough
theory that we can separate kernels in
and Global and uh and non-kernel methods
okay
um so I will actually skip I will skip
this neural collapse part this one I do
allow the weights to rotate but they
can't actually rotate that much because
if the data has the following form that
there's a couple data points over here
and in like a cone and all the rest of
the data is in the in the polar of that
cone then if you have a node that points
in this direction its gradient is always
is going to be a combination of the
nodes in the data points in that little
cone it's never going to move away from
pointing in that direction so that's why
I put low rotation to title this setting
you can prove that that you get trapped
in these in these basins
um and the theorem looks kind of like
what you'd expect
um
and uh
that's the potential function
I will explain it in a moment I want to
spend enough time I want to skip ahead
so I can explain it
um I just want to make a comment about
this
this joke here
uh I'll try to limit what I say here
this is sort of like a
um for people that work in margins or
people that have seen margin papers
often you might see very many
incomparable assumptions in the papers
like the weights are balanced across
layers or the or the loss converges or
the gradients loss converge they're all
these incomparable assumptions
uh when when zoo and I were doing a lot
of these proofs we'd find that many of
them implied each other there'd be like
a graph of implications imply each other
and papers would just kind of pick one
or the other
so we would start when we tried to drop
all of these assumptions we would call
it breaking the Cycles even just cut it
in one place just find one unconditional
property then the whole thing would
follow you just get the theorem
unconditionally however what we would
find is that this was typically
impossible so
the proof plan of proving the
assumptions from those papers
and then just using them as uh as
dilemma we would not be successful we
would have to find a different way to
prove what we wanted that didn't use
that web of implications
so often that web of inflation is just
still be open I'll make this explicit in
a second but um I'm just I'm just
leaving this comment here because if
you've been confused by all these
incomparable assumptions that that's
what's going on there's this like web of
implications
okay so what I want to tell you about
and this is where we'll close
is the global Max margin result for
these scalar Networks
and uh and then we will stop
so these are the networks where I'm
training the ajs and and BJs
and the VJs are fixed so I I fix them
and the way this game is going to work
is that there's some good there's some
good Global Max margin predictor
and basically what I want to argue is
that if a couple VJs if I have if I
sample a couple
values close to those good Global Max
Wireless Solutions then I want to make a
potential function that says all the
mass all the forbidia Storm Master
Network concentrates in those good
directions and then I approve Max margin
okay that's not my proof technique that
switch is unboxed it in their in their
old paper
uh that's my game and if I do that if I
can succeed in getting the global Max
margin up to a constant use uh this this
generalization done by Naughty I can get
the deal repsilon for for two parity
okay
um
so let me just explain you
I think there's nothing oh yeah I want
to say this model is similar to this
model by Natty and Surya and Blake
Woodworth and colleagues that they call
diagonal networks it's somewhat similar
to that model I was inspired by you guys
whatever it's similar enough so
um
so I wanted to explain the potential
function
yes I want to explain the potential
function and how I came up with it
because I realized improve in
constructing this potential function it
caused me to unify many papers so if
I want to tell you guys about this
because it's something I learned that
has not stated in any of the papers and
is maybe more valuable than what I
actually proved so again I want to show
you how many different proof techniques
many papers are actually the same
so there's a very actually kind of
amazing the more I thought about it I
realized this beautiful assumption in
the in the original gradient descent Max
margin paper by by Nati and Daniel
sodrian and hofranax and they had this
assumption they call almost all let me
explain it in my own words so the
technical version of the Assumption is
that the max margin direction if you
look at its support vectors their affine
Hall has Dimension D minus one okay I
don't know about you but to me that
sounds look that's like hard for me to
understand so here's a picture
so here's the max margin direction we're
in the linear case right now sorry we're
the linear case and here are all the
support vectors okay these are data
points such that the inner product with
the maximum direction is is that fixed
constant gamma and we need the max
margin direction to be in the interior
or relative interior of that convex Hall
okay why does this matter this is why I
like this assumption so much
for me this is a very nice intuitive way
to understand why legislative aggression
maximizes margins if we did a w that
starts going away from the maximum
direction if you look at the data point
in this convex Hall on this boundary
that's the farthest away it's going to
pull you back over
okay so if the max marginal Direction
has data points all around it the
farther you get from Maximum Direction
those data points pull you back towards
it there's like a certain strong
convexity over that orthogonal
hyperplane
uh and I I actually used this intuition
and not the intuition from my from my
proofs before to to develop my new
potential function
okay so this at least is how how I
visualize is this very are you okay
is this not what you guys said
I should say that the first the first I
heard this was was not by looking at the
paper um so Zoo AG actually found the
paper and read it and told it to me so
this is his version but he he said it he
gave you guys full credit he said it was
your guys's your guys's idea
but he gave me this proof that I think
is not in your paper which uh this this
is pretty awesome so his proof technique
says if your weight Vector WT if it's
projection onto the orthogonal
complement
of the maximum Direction okay if you're
pointing far away from it so if this is
large in other words if WT projected
here is large
then if you just look at DDT
of this of that thing squared it must be
negative let's just say to get in words
if if you're far away from X minor
Direction then your derivative project
on that hyperplane must be negative
which means it can never be that large
because it has to go back down
okay there has to be like a like a fixed
point there has to be a point where it
cannot get above because it's a
contradiction it can't you can't be
above that point and have a negative
derivative
or let me say it like maybe in pictures
if your WT projected onto this this uh
convicts Hall is getting farther and
farther from you
there's kind of a limit after which you
you can't pass because the derivative on
that plane would be negative
and and the the proof by the way that
Zoe has it's in one of our old papers
it's very short it's just like algebra
it's kind of kind of brilliant it's
completely his it's I didn't have any
role in that proof and um it actually
reminds me of another old idea because
I've just been throwing around a lot of
old ideas there's a proof by uh Phil
Long and rockoster video about convex
potential boosters being sensitive to
noise and they they had a very different
construction but it had a similar
intuition these are like they call them
poolers and they kind of pull you back
okay just throwing out a lot of
uh yes a lot of older papers
okay so now uh so I'll tell you how to
translate this into two homogeneous
networks and then and then we'll stop
so another way of writing this if you
just expand the square is you get the
first term and some cancellations so
there's WT
which is
um
yeah the norm of all of your weights
I mean right now it's linear case but
just think of it as always weights and
then you have the projection of WT on
the good direction
what I spent almost all of my time
working on this project doing was trying
to understand what the projection of the
global Max margin solution is onto your
architecture I was trying to understand
how to generalize this projection to two
homogeneous Networks
and for those of you that have not seen
this before
um
okay let me let me do it this way I'm
going to show you a few Expressions that
are going to have problems then I'll
tell you how I fixed them with potential
we won't have time to understand it
because of my fault I mismanaged time
and then we'll stop for questions let me
show you something cool so if I just
look at DDT
of my parameter Vector squared for a two
homogeneous Network you can just
calculate this out you use some chain
rule right we get two the parameters in
the parameter time derivative if you
work this out
I get the derivatives of all the losses
w
I mean that's not really a gradient but
I'll just call it a gradient
and um use homogeneity
you get uh
this okay so this thing
um
kind of looks like the margin
now the problem I encountered when I
tried to do this over on the other side
was that this thing scales with Norm of
W squared and what I would get in the
other term when I would try to adapt it
to to two homogeneous networks is um if
I had like multiple different directions
and I was trying to figure out let's say
the how much the network is fluctuating
in different directions they'd always be
scaled by these Norms so I couldn't
really relate them back to the original
Global Max margin Direction there was
this there was this imbalance
and so to fix it let me just give you
one more technical idea if you look in
the papers of chizatenbach and a paper
by kaifung View and Gian Li they have a
solution to this problem
so what Shazam box did is they look at
this weight ratio and when you DDT the
weight ratio of two different nodes you
normalize the output of the node by a
screening storm squared you make it have
like the order of the margin make it
like constant order you you cancel out
it's it's this Norm
so that was one solution with Shazam
Bach they did this DDT of this ratio and
and kaifen Liu and Jen Lee they did
something similar they looked at the log
of the weights which similarly Kicks
Down the norm
okay so so what am I telling you in so
many words because I know I'm not being
that coherent all I want to say is this
potential is a nice way to kind of move
back to the max margin Direction
80 has this scale issue I couldn't
figure out and one solution is to do
these ratios
um that's not the end of the story the
final potential I worked with
uh
did I even put it in this yes it's it's
a monster actually it's it's this thing
and we I think it'll just be a waste of
time I think it'll just be ugly if we
try to go through it but the the the
bottom line I want to tell you is that
um
yeah how do I summarize this coherently
yeah I'll summarize it this way that if
you try to design such a potential
function that does this projection of
the global Max marketing solution onto
your network weights
the issue you run into are all these
imbalances this is like that cycle
problem I talked about I couldn't figure
out how to solve it but I figured out a
potential point that sort of just
removes them and this potential function
has every magical property that proves
the theorem which is not very satisfying
for the person to talk but uh yeah I'll
just I'll just leave it at that now let
me actually just go back to the theorem
and explain the theorem and then uh
we'll stop because yeah I was too
ambitious with time and is explaining
the proof
so I will just say that
um yeah the point is I have these scalar
Networks
okay and they can prove Global Max
margin oh I should say what is the
closest prior works the closest prior
work is either the paper by this one by
Colin way at all uh Conway changlu Jason
Lee and Antonio ma that I mentioned they
have to use this noisy washer Stein flow
they can't use gradient flow but they
get Global Max margins similar results
or the result which is on Bach that
needs the infinite support the infinite
width Plus
the um
dual convergence
and
um yes this gets a comparable result uh
just with these scalar things so the
next open prom of course a lot of inner
weights to vary
which I think that's why I want to show
the potential function I think it'll
help with that but I I ran out of time
so let me just summarize then we can
stop I apologize that not handle the
last 10 minutes that well so just to
summarize and just say what I think are
the most interesting points
so two layer networks train both layers
uh the first proof is this uh what what
Spencer was calling style or what I call
perceptron Style
um and I guess what was exciting here
was that if you look at the width in the
sample complex we need for for this two
sparse parity it's it's very tight is
very good within the within the ntk
um the width is is worse than theirs
um and this is already enough to say
that we get non-trivial margins and
Escape these KET points that was the
first part of the talk
to be honest stronger than the second
half this second half just looks hard
um in the second half with some cases
with global Max margin
and I would say
um open problems just to give people
something to think about for the first
part a very direct open problem once I
post a paper is is to make SGD
and gradient flow
closer like I think it's a good way to
actually explore generalization balance
why did I have to use such a complicated
proof to get a good generalization bound
and for the second part it would be to
um
one question is to drop the vj's not
rotating and I'd say a second open
problem is to um make make this more
practical so if you have a very small
width what happens instead of this
ridiculous you know cfar Dimension is
2072 so uh yeah having 3s and A2 and the
exponents uh
not great okay I'll stop there thank you
foreign
okay I want to be able to say that your
current margin minus something like your
projection
so I want this projection to scale with
gamma and what ends up happening is you
have a potential function on the left
that's what you can prove is lower
bounded by zero this part goes to minus
infinity if if this if your margin is
always worse than the optimal margin
then this goes to my so I need to
exhibit this how do I exhibit this
the most naive way is you get an
expression that looks like
if you have these clusters of
nodes that point in the same direction
as the Google Max monitor Direction I
get a sum over these clusters and I get
I get um my my margins on those points
now the problem is that this scales with
the amount of mass I have on that node
so if I have some node that it just
happened to happen it happened through
random aspects of training that it just
the weights were just huge and then
there was another one small I mean
intuitively should fix itself right
gradient descent will just say oh you
don't need to trains anymore go in this
direction but in the proof it becomes a
disaster you have these imbalances and
now I can't relate the school next
margin that's why using this log is
magical it normalizes this and it
balance it balances the weights within
the proof so so this is the key thing my
my potential function
for each cluster of nodes that point in
one of the max marginal directions
inside all the nodes that point in that
in that direction I take the log of that
sum
and then I sum over the Clusters outside
the log so it's like a product of the
sums and don't even ask me how I found
this potential function
okay sorry that took one minute but does
that make at least some sense
I can tell you offline too
thank you
it's a reception outside you're uh
welcome to all welcome to join uh enjoy
whatever it is
tomorrow morning at 9 30.
thank you